then just days ago Mike Pence sent his
personal attorney to search his family's
home in Carmel Indiana for classified
documents
now if Mike Pence didn't think he had
classified documents why would he send
his lawyer to go look for classified
documents hmm we can't say for certain
but it's entirely possible in fact it's
likely that Mike Pence was asked to do
this by federal prosecutors who are
trying to build a case against his old
boss Donald whoa now the point would be
to show that not every federal official
walks off of State Secrets Donald Trump
was uniquely evil in that regard as in
so many others and again he's minimizing
the fact that the Trump situation is so
dramatically different than the Biden or
Pence situations
stole versus misplaced refused to give
back versus immediately turned over used
lawyers to prevent returning the
documents versus used lawyers to
immediately return the documents but
Tucker doesn't want you to think about
any of those differences